PETER-MARK VERWOERD: As I was
preparing for this session
today I realized
that I'm going to be
in the uncomfortable position
of basically mispronouncing
my own name to a
bunch of Dutch people.
I've been getting this
question all day long.
I am half Dutch.
My father was born here.
But I'm Canadian,
I grew up there.
So my name is
Peter-Mark Verwoerd,
which is how we pronounce
it over in Canada.
I know I'm mispronouncing it.
I'm on the solution architecture
team here at Google Cloud.
And what I usually do and what
I spend a lot of my time with
is helping customers migrate
to the cloud, whether coming
from data centers, other
private clouds, and so on.
And what we end up
spending a lot of time on
is actually data and databases.
It's always a topic of concern
with a lot of customers.
And what that actually
ends up meaning
is that I talk about Cloud
Spanner a great deal.
One more thing, I know
I'm the very last session
before cocktail
hour so I'm going
to try to be as efficient
as possible with my time,
especially considering
our small delay.
I don't want to be the only
thing between a group of people
and some drinks.
So off we go.
And so what I'm going
to try to cover today
is a brief history of
Spanner, why it was created.
What was the
motivation at Google?
What is Cloud Spanner as
it has been released today?
How does it work?
How does it compare
to other things?
And then, finally, a
brief demo that we better
get to considering all the
work that went into it.
So why does Spanner exist?
And to get to that you really
have to go back to about 2005.
At that time pretty much every
dollar that Google generated
was based off of AdWords.
And AdWords was backed by
a manually sharded MySQL
database.
And that database was
sharded on customer keys--
or customer IDs, rather.
And, as we grew we had
to reshard that database.
And we had to reshard it a lot
because we were growing really
quickly.
And the reshards were
getting increasingly painful,
to the point where the last one
actually took several years,
literally, to complete.
At that point we said, you
know, this is untenable.
We can't continue this way.
There has to be
something better.
And so something better led
to essentially the development
of Spanner.
And so while we
were planning out
what eventually
became Spanner, we
had to sort through what
our requirements were.
And, essentially,
at that time, those
were, what were
AdWords' requirements?
And so there were
three big ones.
First, it had to be a
horizontally scalable database.
This was the problem we
were encountering already
with MySQL.
We had to solve for that.
And so we needed something
that could scale with us.
We had gone from a $10 million a
year company to over $1 billion
a year in such a short time.
And we knew the
scale wasn't ending.
It was only going
to be more and more.
And so we had to be
horizontally scalable.
Second, we had to have
asset transactions.
We were dealing with money,
budgets, customers, partners,
agencies.
We had to be sure that
any transaction that
got written to the database
was a strong transaction.
We couldn't deal with
eventual consistency,
we couldn't accept data loss.
We had to have asset
transactions in consistency.
And then finally, we
couldn't afford downtime.
AdWords was the thing that
was driving all of Google
at the time.
So every minute, every second
that AdWords was down meant
lost revenue to Google.
And so downtime was
unacceptable for any system
that we were creating to
replace the existing one.
So we had to have up time.
And so if you look at
these three requirements
and think about what was
available at the time,
there was really
nothing that could
fit those requirements in the
market until Cloud Spanner.
And so that brings us to
what Cloud Spanner is.
And if you could play
the video now, please.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- We demand a lot
of our databases,
and our databases
demand a lot of us.
They're fragile, expensive,
and tough to maintain.
When things break, it can be
hard to put the pieces back
together at the speed
of your business,
and you often lose
data in the process.
We've all come to expect that
distributed databases can't
be globally consistent
and scalable.
But what if you didn't
have to make tradeoffs?
What if you could have a
fully managed database service
that's consistent,
scales horizontally
across data centers,
and speaks SQL?
This is Cloud Spanner, a
mission-critical relational
database service built
from the ground up
and battle-tested at Google
for strong consistency
and high availability
at global scale.
At Google we use
Spanner for services
that billions of people
access every day.
It's the only cloud
service designed
to be a massively
distributed relational
database with transactions
and SQL semantics.
And we're talking massive.
Spanner can scale up to millions
of machines across hundreds
of data centers and trillions
of database rows stretching
across the globe while
behaving like it's all in one
place, where you want it.
We've built Cloud Spanner to
be fully managed and secure.
Automatic sharding and
synchronous replication
with low latency and schema
updates without downtime
means your data is highly
available and reliable.
Instead of endless provisioning
and worrying about maintenance,
you can focus on
growing your business.
No matter your
needs, you don't have
to hit a wall with
your database service.
Get started with Cloud
Spanner and build what's next.
[END PLAYBACK]
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: All right.
So I'm just here to
introduce that video.
Thank you very much
everyone, goodbye--
kidding.
So that's just an overview
of what Cloud Spanner does.
And when you dive into
it, what is Cloud Spanner?
And how does that
relate to what Spanner
was as an internal product?
So first of all, Spanner is a
fully managed database service,
which means that you don't
have to worry about upgrades,
patching, security, keeping it
online, or anything like that.
That's all done by our own
site reliability engineering
team that makes sure
that Spanner is up 24/7.
As you may imagine, we get
fairly pedantic at Google
actually about a
number of things.
But one of them is about
what does consistency mean?
And what does global
consistency mean?
And for us, it means
external serializability.
And that's a highest
standard for what
global consistency means.
And there's a lot of
discussion inside the industry
about eventual consistency
versus global, and what
really that is versus
what's acceptable.
For us, we had to
set the highest
bar possible for
what our needs were,
and Spanner meets that bar.
And so that means that
you get asset transactions
across many rows.
You have relational semantics.
You've got DDLs that
you can create tables.
You can do inserts, updates,
deletes, queries using SQL.
And, in fact, you
can use the same SQL
that's already available
across Google Cloud
Platform for BigQuery.
So AntiSQL 2011
with some extensions
is the same SQL that you use
in BigQuery that you can also
use on Cloud Platform.
We also have automated
synchronous replication.
As of today, so we
have regional Spanner.
So you can create regional
instances of Spanner.
And those are within
a single region
spread across many zones.
And that gives you four
nines of availability.
And so when you
write to Spanner,
no matter where you're
writing it within the region,
you know that write is
accepted and committed.
And later this year
we will be rolling out
multi-regional Spanner
which actually gives you
a higher level of availability.
That gives you five
nines of availability,
which is about two seconds
of downtime per month.
And so that's going to be
coming later this year.
And finally, we've been
using this internally
at Google for nearly 10 years.
This is battle-tested.
This has been run on production
systems for a long time.
And the reason I can get up
here and make these claims
about consistency,
about availability
is because we've been
doing this for so long.
We've got the data,
we've got the history
to know that we can
stand by these claims.
And in fact, in
addition to AdWords,
which has been using Spanner
since it went into production,
there are a lot of
other systems at Google
that use Spanner as well.
So the Play Store uses Spanner.
Google Cloud Platform, in
fact, also uses Spanner.
The data plane that
maintains all the VMs
across Cloud Platform actually
runs on top of Spanner.
So I just said a lot of
things about how it works
and ways it doesn't work.
But in a more concrete
sense, what does that mean?
So I think it's useful to
compare it to both relational
databases and NoSQL databases,
which is where we often
get the most questions.
So if you compare it to
a relational database,
Spanner has SQL.
Spanner does schema updates.
It has strong consistency.
And where the comparison
gets interesting
is we often get
questions like, well,
how does Spanner compare to my
RDBMS, MySQL [? plus plus, ?]
whatever it is?
And that's-- sometimes can be an
apples and oranges comparison.
Because when you
talk about an RDBMS,
you're usually talking
about a single node system
where all the reads
and writes are
going through a single
node, a particular node.
And Spanner is a
distributed system.
And so with a single
node system like
that, if you've got any issues
like unexpected downtime,
like unexpected
failure of a node,
you have to do security patches,
you have to do an upgrade,
you have downtime
with that system.
And you can create
alternative strategies
where you have things
like master-master-slaves,
or read slaves
where you failover.
And those alleviate the
downtime but there is still
downtime that is incurred.
And with Spanner, again, part
of our design requirements
was that we couldn't
have downtime.
And so there was that kind of--
there's that kind of change
and that difference there.
And so basically the strategy
for Spanner becomes--
it's a horizontal
strategy for scaling.
Meanwhile, with a
single node database
your strategy is
vertical scaling.
You go to say, I
need a bigger box.
I need more RAM.
I need more memory, more
disk, what have you.
I hope the provider I have has a
bigger VM because we're hitting
the limits on our database.
With Spanner, that issue's gone.
It doesn't have that
problem anymore.
Now the other thing you can do
to scale relational databases
is add read replicas.
And so you alleviate that
load on top of the master node
and spread the reads out
to the read replicas,
you increase your capacity
of the master node.
But then you have to deal
with replication lag.
And so if you have
to be sure, you
have to be positive
that what you're reading
is the most consistent view.
You can go back to the master
to get the most consistent view,
but then you're consuming
the resources that you
had set aside for writes.
And so that's a
situation that just
doesn't happen with Spanner.
And on the other hand, with
non-relational databases,
we often see the
situation where we
go to customers, large and
small across the board, where
we see a very familiar pattern.
An application is created.
It has a relational
database on the back end.
The application grows
for whatever reason,
becomes very popular.
It starts throwing a
lot of data, and so on.
At a certain point the
relational database
is replaced by a
NoSQL database--
Cassandra, MongoDB,
whatever it is.
And when that
decision happens, it
is usually done by saying our
top priority in this change
is horizontal scalability.
So we're willing to
sacrifice consistency
if we can get that scalability.
And so that trade off
is made, and then you
start pushing all
this logic that
once existed by the
nature of the database
into the application.
So you're starting
to create consistency
within an application,
which is introducing
more complexity, more
maintenance, more bugs
for the sake of gaining
horizontal scalability.
And with Spanner you don't
have to make that trade-off.
You can continue to
scale horizontally,
but you still have consistency.
You still have
asset transactions.
One of the things we
get asked a lot about
is, what was the
hardest part of bringing
Spanner from an internal
product to a Cloud product?
And I think one of the things
that we worked hardest on
was making it open.
So Google is very much
about being an open cloud
and meeting you where
you are with the tools
that you already use.
And so we tried to inject
this across the board
into Cloud Spanner.
So the first thing we started
with was using standard SQL.
Like I said earlier, this
is the same SQL dialect
that is spoken by
BigQuery right now.
A couple of years ago, we
looked at our products.
We said we were--
honestly we were all over the
map with SQL standardization.
So we decided to standardize
AntiSQL 2011 extensions.
And that is currently
used by BigQuer.
Now it's also used by Spanner.
And so we wanted to make
sure we standardize that
and made it a familiar
language for anyone
who's making that transition.
Second, we spent a lot of
time on enterprise features.
So at launch--
Spanner launched back in March--
when it launched, it launched
with the most features
of any of our new
products had ever
launched with, things like
encryption, identity and access
management logging, all
these sorts of things
that any kind of
standard enterprise
would be interested in
and be required to use
a database in production.
And Spanner launched
with those on day one.
A third was to make
Spanner an appealing
target for developers.
We want to be a developer
friendly platform.
And in order to
do that, we really
think there are two
essential things.
One, you have to have
great documentation.
And two, you have to
have good libraries.
And so for the
documentation, Spanner
was actually in early
access for over 12 months.
So we have an early access
program with some customers.
And it was there
for over a year.
And among the many things that
we did with our early access
customers was actually
refine our documentation.
They told us where the holes
were, where the gaps were,
things didn't make sense, things
weren't explained well enough.
And we iterated over, and over,
and over on that documentation.
And it really helped a lot to be
able to make the documentation
at launch really first class.
Alongside that process was
developing client libraries.
So we really wanted to launch
with a wide variety of popular
platforms-- or popular
languages, I should say--
with our libraries.
And so we launched with Java
and Python and Node and Go.
And those are really
first class libraries.
What we've done
with those is tried
to make it as easy as
possible for developers
who are familiar
with those languages
to get started and start
using Spanner in a way that's
familiar, in a way that is
natural in that language.
We've abstracted away a lot
of the subtle intricacies
of connecting to Spanner,
of using the API,
in a way that makes sense
for each particular language.
And then finally we
launched with a JDBC driver.
So we knew it was
important for Spanner
to be able to connect
to existing tools,
especially existing BI tools.
And so we launched with a
JDBC driver that's read-only.
And so what that means is
you can connect your Spanner
instance to tools that you
already use, that you already
have, and to be able to
read the data off of there.
And so that's the kind of thing
that you can do for customers.
Whether they're
internal or external,
if they want to read
the data, if they
want to connect to
want to build reporting
off that data,
that is something they can
do with that JDBC driver.
So the type of
workloads that we expect
most customers to use
with Spanner mostly
fall into these four categories.
And this is
something that we saw
in the early access
and something
that we've seen since
Spanner has launched.
And the first is transactional.
And this isn't really
surprising at all.
It is a relational database.
It has strong transactional
requirements--
strong transactional
capabilities, I should say.
And so we see a lot
of transactional use
cases, which is not surprising.
If you've got a use case where
you're selling something,
you can't sell more than
you actually possess,
or you want to
record transactions,
you want to record
financial transactions,
Spanner's a great
use case for that.
And we saw this happening a
lot, especially in those cases
where companies, in
order to maintain
a certain size or
a certain scale,
had built in a lot
of consistency logic
into an application
rather than the database.
And Spanner being able
to take on that logic
from the application and
being able to lighten
the load on development
and bug maintenance.
Second, scale-out.
So we often find ourselves
trying to answer the question,
do I have to have a minimum
data set size to use Spanner?
Does it have to be
hundreds of terabytes
so I can really
efficiently use it?
Absolutely not.
You can start using Spanner and
start getting a really good use
case out of Spanner
even at very small,
say single-digit
gigabyte-sized databases.
Because part of the advantage
of Spanner is not just storage.
The advantage here
is that you're
gaining this
availability and you're
gaining the consistency of
that availability spread
across a region.
And so if you've got some kind
of mission critical database,
if you've got something that
you absolutely have to have
the highest level of
availability possible,
if you've got something that
cannot go down if at all
possible, and it's
got to be relational,
it's got to be stored reliably,
Spanner's a great use case.
And this is
something that we see
a lot of customers
using where they really
relied on the
availability rather
than the size and
the scale in order
to use for their applications,
Third, and this is a very,
very common use case at Google,
is a global data plan.
If you've got a
user base, let's say
you've got a global user base.
You've got users in the States.
You've got users in Europe.
You've got users in Asia.
And they all log into
the same application.
But you're sharding along
that geographic user database.
So you keep a database in each
one of those three regions,
and those users are home there.
When a user logs in, you've
got to figure out how
to send them to the right home.
So even if you're homed
in the right place,
how do you know where
that person's home is?
And so you've got to have
some sort of meta database
to be able to
describe where to go.
And that's solved by putting
that database somewhere,
and two groups of people
live with bad latency.
And so you can solve
that by using Spanner
as an actual global
database where you get
much lower latency to reads.
And then finally,
database consolidation.
So where this has
been really useful
is if you think
of, say, a system
where you need to
do some analytics
and you've got your customer
transactions in a MySQL
database.
You've got analytics
sitting in a data warehouse
and you're pulling in
log files from storage.
And you want to bring them
all into a single place
so you will run
analytics on top of that,
you put them in reports.
Where you've got data basically
in a lot of different places,
and you've got to
bring it together
for a single source
of truth before you
can start doing reporting,
Spanner can actually
replace all of that.
So Spanner can be
that source of truth.
It can be that location
where everything goes anyway.
And you run reporting
on top of that.
And so we saw that
happen a great deal, too.
So after talking about
Spanner in the abstract,
how does this thing
actually work?
So it's pretty easy to
create a Spanner instance.
I'm going to walk
through that shortly.
When you create an
instance, you're basically
telling the Spanner
service, what
do you want your replication
topology to look like?
You create a node, you
create multiple nodes--
however many nodes within
a particular region--
and you select that region.
And then each of those nodes
has replicas across the region.
And so all this data is getting
replicated automatically
across the region.
A few limits-- an
instance of Cloud Spanner
can have up to 100
databases within it.
And each database can
have 2,000 tables.
But within each
table you can have
an unlimited number of rows.
The nodes themselves do have
a limit per storage and QPS.
So what happens when
you try to do an update?
What happens when you
try to write something
to your Spanner instance?
What happens is it
comes into the cluster,
and Spanner, in some
sort of magical way,
determines who is the owner
of this particular data.
It is replicated
across each zone,
but each particular node--
or, within Spanner, there
are particular nodes
that own chunks of data.
They are the primary
writer of this data.
And the rest of
them are replicas.
And so Spanner-- again,
more or less by magic--
determines who that owner is
and sends it to that owner,
and they write it.
We use a custom
Paxos algorithm that
allows us to do consensus-based
writing that is not all voters
need to agree.
You just need a majority.
And that gives us our
global consistency.
That gives us an
ability to quickly do
writes but still be consistent.
There are times when we will do
a two-phase commit, especially
if you're going across
nodes if there's
more than one owner of the
data that you're writing.
But we try to avoid that because
our Paxos algorithm actually
writes the data faster.
But we want to do
whatever we can
to ensure that we have
global consistency.
So how does that actually work
in terms of actually using it?
If we consider a normal
relational database use case,
let's think about these
two tables together.
And so you have a singers table,
and you've got an album table.
In a regular relational database
you build out each table.
You make a primary key of
singer ID, primary key album ID.
And then if you wanted
Albums to be a child table,
you make that a composite key
or you make it a foreign key.
And so you've got some foreign
key constraints on top of that.
As magical-- or,
at least I believe,
it's magical-- as magical
as Spanner sounds,
it can't do everything
identically.
There have to be trade-offs
with how it works.
And the trade-offs are
in particular with how
tables relate to
each other and how
tables depend on each other.
And so to do this,
in Spanner we do
something slightly different.
We actually interleave
the tables together.
And this is essentially
telling Spanner,
this is data that I
commonly query together.
This is data I commonly
update together.
Please leave them in
the same data location.
And so that is what
interleaving table does.
From a conceptual
point of view, this
is the same thing as
two related tables
with a parent-child
relationship.
And you set it up the same way.
So you set up the Artist table
with Artist ID, Artist Name.
And then in an Album table
with Album ID, Album Name.
But then you tell
Spanner, instead
of saying create
a foreign key, I'm
going to interleave this
table with the previous one.
And I would like to-- or
not, if you don't want to--
inject a dependency on this.
So if you delete one, I
want you to delete the child
relationships.
So what does this
actually look like?
If you're familiar with SQL,
it should look pretty familiar,
actually.
This is actually valid
DDL syntax for Spanner.
So creating the Singers table
is pretty straightforward.
I think that would
run on most databases.
Albums, again, pretty
straightforward.
And the real difference
here is that you
want to interleave Singers
onto this database.
And so it's going to
know that Singer ID is
that primary key from the
interleaving parent table.
And you've made Album ID
the primary key as well.
And so one thing that's
really neat about Spanner,
and is very different, I think,
from relational databases
in a good way, is that
you can make table changes
without taking your
database offline.
You can make table changes live,
and there's no interruption
in your service or performance.
And so let's say that we wanted
to add an age to our Singers
table.
Then we just alter the table.
And everyone continues.
And that's now part of
that table definition.
And whoever is
reading it and writing
it will start using
it right away,
which is pretty cool, actually.
And so how does it
actually look in code?
Like I said, we've got
support for Go, Java, Python,
no JS right now.
This is Python code, in
case you're not familiar.
I'm not really a Python guy.
I'm more Java.
But somebody was kind enough
to write this up for me,
so I'm not going to
really complain too much.
But the process is relatively
similar everywhere.
You can go to command line
install this library from PIP,
do PIP install,
Google Cloud Library.
And then in your Python file
import the Spanner library,
instantiate a client.
You'd say, client, I would like
an instance ID from Spanner.
And then with that
instance ID, you're
going to grab your
handle to your instance.
And then once you grab the
handle to the instance,
you say, all right,
I would like you
to return me a handle to
database of whatever name
so I can get a handle
on that database.
And then you can
start executing SQL.
And this right here, this
Execute SQL statement,
is just a regular SQL query.
As long it's AntiSQL 2011,
it's going to be fine.
And so you can just
execute SQL queries
right there, which is,
for a lot of use cases,
going to be very similar to
what a lot of existing code
already does.
So a couple of things
that I want to touch on
before I get to the demo
is, how does Spanner
fit into the existing
portfolio of cloud products?
I admit that this
can get confusing
and/or daunting at
times, especially
if you're not familiar
with how they all work.
And so we do try
to spell out where
we think the best
recommendations are
for each of these products.
So we want to start on--
oh, shoot, back.
We want to start on this
side with Cloud SQL.
So Cloud SQL is managed
MySQL and Postgres.
And so if you've got,
say, a web framework
that relies on MySQL like,
say, Django, or WordPress,
or what have you, that's
a really good use case.
If you've got a small
data set, if you
don't have high availability
requirements where
you can afford some
measure of downtime,
MySQL's a good fit there.
If you've got a NoSQL
document store use case,
this is a lot of web frameworks,
a lot of websites use this.
Cloud Datastore is really
a good option for that.
Because Cloud Datastore
is shared resources,
you start by paying nothing,
and then you pay as you use.
And so you can really
grow with Datastore.
Probably the most well
known example of Datastore
is Snapchat.
So Snapchat started
out real small.
They have gotten very big.
And they've been using
Datastore the whole time.
So you can really go from
very, very small to very, very
large on Datastore.
On the other hand, Bigtable's
more of an analytics database.
Very, very high speed, low
latency, like single digit
millisecond response times
for time series data,
for financial analysis,
for IoT analysis.
Bigtable is really particularly
well-suited for that.
And then finally over
here is BigQuery.
So BigQuery is a cloud
enterprise data warehouse.
It is for large scale
analytics, reporting,
really the end point for data
so that it can be in a place
that it can be
analyzed long term.
And so where Spanner
fits into all of this
is Spanner is good for mission
critical databases that
require high availability,
regional access.
And then later on this year
when we release multi-region,
it will be for this
global data plan use
case that is not well suited for
the rest of these applications.
And then the slide you
guys got a sneak peek at,
we do understand, despite
those explanations,
sometimes it can be hard
to figure out where does
my particular use case lie?
And so we came up
with this flowchart.
It's not 100% perfect, but
it does help a great deal
by making some kind
of broad assumptions
and broad decisions.
And so the decision
tree basically goes,
your first decision,
is this structured?
If it's not
structured, it really
should go into object storage.
So that's Cloud Storage.
If you're using-- or if you
need to store unstructured data
from a mobile platform,
then what you can do use
is the Firebase SDK to get
to Firebase Storage, which
is backed by Cloud Storage.
On the other hand,
so it is structured,
if you have an analytics
workload, what you really
need to investigate,
is it something that's
going to require updates,
it's going to require changes
in low latency?
In which case, it's more
of Bigtable use case.
If not, then that's BigQuery.
And then going down
the main branch again,
if it is non-relational
data, then Datastore
is a good use case if you're
not using a mobile platform.
And again, if you're
using a mobile platform,
Firebase Realtime DB
is a great solution
for non-relational data.
And then finally, if you
do have relational data,
the decision comes
down to, do you need
that horizontal scalability?
Do you need that
higher availability?
In that case, the
answer is Spanner.
If not, then Cloud
SQL works pretty well.
Finally, before the
demo, you've probably
heard in a couple
of sessions today
that partner integrations
are very important to us.
We want to make sure
that partners that you're
working with, software
that you're working with,
works with our new
and existing products.
And so launching with
a lot of partners
was really important to us.
And we launched with
Xplenty, Zoomdata, Looker.
Pretty much anyone you're
working with or using,
we are working to make sure
that our shared customers will
be able to take advantage
of all the things
that we create together.
And so if we do
support it today,
I hope you're using it and
taking advantage of it.
If we're not, it's something
we're actively working on.
All right.
So with that, we're
going to try this demo.
Cool, it works.
All right.
So if you're going to start
with Spanner, if you're
curious about how
it goes, I really,
really strongly recommend
looking at the documentation.
We really did
spend a lot of time
on this, a lot of iterations.
And it is very, very extensive.
So it goes from concepts to
quite a few how-to guides,
diving into each of
the tutorials for each
of the libraries, API reference,
resources, all sorts of stuff.
It's really actually very, very
deep and extremely well done.
So I strongly recommend
checking out the documentation.
So now what I'm
going to do in my own
Cloud console is
I'm actually going
to create a Spanner instance.
And it's bookmarked
because Spanner's awesome.
And I'm going to show you just
how quickly this can be done.
So let's call this next.
And it's going to autofill that.
We are going to select
Europe because that's
where we're sitting.
And let's say 10 nodes I
think is enough for here.
And it'll show you how
much it costs per hour.
It has some guidance around
what kind of capacity
each of these nodes
are capable of
and what you're signing up for.
And we're going to create that.
And let's see.
Oh dear, it took
like three seconds.
What are they doing?
So anyway, this
is actually live.
This is not some sort of nicety
that the console does for you.
This is actually a live
status of your cluster--
or instance, rather-- as
soon as you create it.
So this is up and running.
So those 10 nodes are now mine.
But all you've done
is create a Spanner,
for lack of a better term.
And this is not the
same kind of thing.
This is essentially a
container of databases.
You haven't created
any databases.
There's nothing to
query, nothing to insert.
So you've got to go ahead
and create a database.
And so why don't we replicate
the example from earlier?
We're going to create
a small music database.
And I'm just going to
create these in the console.
These are all options that you
could do from the command line
and from--
there we go-- from
any of the libraries.
And so I'm just doing this
because obviously it's
a little easier.
Oh, Artists, that's
not the primary key.
There we go.
So Artist ID.
This keyboard is not
an English keyboard.
So we're going to require that.
We're going to add,
let's say Artist's Name.
And we'll make that a string.
It did it again.
There, OK.
And we'll require
the name as well.
We'll continue.
We'll make the Artist
ID the primary key.
And away we go.
And so now what
we're going to do
is actually add the
interleaved tile table.
So we'll call this Album.
And we're going to
interleave this.
We're going to interleave
it with Artists
It's the only
choice, but you could
have a drop down
of whatever tables
you have in this database.
We're also going to
say cascade on delete.
So delete parent
child rows together.
And so in this case, we
inherit Artist ID automatically
because we've already
told Spanner that it's
going to be interleaved.
And I'm going to make
an Album ID required.
And we're going to
make a Album Name.
make that a string
and say it's also
required, Done, Continue.
And again, because
we're inheriting
this as an interleaved table,
part of the primary key
is already the
parent primary key.
And it's requiring
a composite key.
So we're going to select
Album ID as the second part
of the composite key.
And we're done.
And so now we can go ahead
and create our database.
And in a couple of seconds,
yep, we have tables with columns
that we can start
reading and writing from.
But as I sit here
and think about it,
I really think we
should edit Albums
because when you're
looking at Albums,
you probably want to
look at a release date.
It seems pretty important.
So why don't we add Release
Date and make that a date type.
Yes, we're going to
require that, too.
Done, Save, and we've
updated our database
and we haven't told
it to go offline.
We haven't had a
maintenance window.
We just continued
along as before.
This is a pretty neat
feature of the console
in that you can look
at the equivalent
DDL for any of the tables.
And, in fact, the entire
database has the same feature.
So if we go up here, we'll
see the DDL for this database.
And that's available
to you at any point.
Another feature that we
have is for the database.
You can look at the
monitoring on that database
as you're using it.
So CPU, operations per
second, throughput, and so on.
This is on every
single database.
And, in fact, for
the instance itself,
also has that same monitoring
enabled right away.
So you can look at node count
and some similar features.
And now that we've been
using this for a little bit,
I realize I'm massively
over provisioned.
So I think 10 nodes
is way too much.
Why don't we go down to five?
And save that.
And our Spanner
instance has continued,
again without downtime,
again without end users being
affected at all
because apparently we
were over provisioned.
And so everything
continues just fine.
So now what I'm going to do
is go into a different Spanner
database that was created
by one of my colleagues,
conveniently called Europe
Spanner Demo Instance.
And this has quite a
bit more data in it.
So at least we can
do some queries here.
And so this database is
backing essentially a ticketing
application-- think like
Ticketmaster or something
like that-- where
you have artists
who go on tours to
different venues which
have a certain number of
tickets and ticket categories,
and users who come in and
purchase tickets, spend
a certain amount of money.
And so they need
accounts, and they
need financial information.
So a relatively classic
relational database use case.
This is something
that you really
need strong transactions.
When people buy
tickets for concerts,
they probably expect
those to actually happen.
So if we look at this
database, again we've
got a few indexes
on some tables,
we've got some interleaved
tables, some children tables
in places that you may imagine.
We're using about 600 gigs.
So let's do a query.
And let's take advantage
of writing things down.
So I'm going to take this query.
And what we're looking for
is events in the Netherlands
at venues that have a
significant percentage
of unsold tickets.
So you could imagine making
this query and saying,
well, these couple of venues
for these events don't have--
are largely unsold.
Let's do a marketing event,
let's do a special, something
like that.
So let's run a query on
what's available here.
And we've got two venues that
have 9,664 seats available.
And that's the total
number of seats.
So it looks like there are
zero sold on that first one,
and the second one, same story.
So they are not doing well.
Whatever this event is,
it's not very popular.
And with every query that
you make through the console,
you can actually look
at the explain plan.
And you can look
at what happened,
what did the optimizer
do, how did Spanner
go through the query and read
your data, and find your data?
And so you can dive into that.
We previously looked
at this and said,
there's probably
an optimization we
can make here to make
this a little bit better.
We took about 3/4 of a second
to run the query and scanned
nearly 15,000 rows.
So what we're going
to do is actually--
this is one of the features
that we have in the SQL spec--
is being able to force
an index on the query.
And so we're going to
force an index on--
oh, dear, I've lost it.
Where's Demo 2?
Oh, dear.
We're going to force an--
on here.
So this is the syntax
on, I think, event date.
So here we go.
We're going to try this on
the fly and see if it runs.
No, it didn't.
Nope.
This is why you
write things down.
Nope.
All right.
I'm terribly sorry.
So if that had worked,
basically what you can do
is modify your query by
looking at the explain plan.
And that's something
I strongly recommend.
I also strongly recommend
writing things down
in the right places.
I do apologize for that.
That's not what I'm meant to do.
But it does give you
a lot of versatility
and a lot of tooling to
enable you to actually analyze
your queries.
So if you're having queries that
are running in ways that you
don't expect, if you think
they're taking too long,
if you think they're
not working or returning
the right number of rows,
do look at the explain plan.
Do look at what
Spanner's actually doing
when you execute that query.
And you can really actually
get quite a bit out of that.
It might be things
like force index.
It might be things like
interleaving different tables.
adding indexes to tables.
So do look at that.
There is a lot of
information there
in order to help you
along and to improve
how you interact with Spanner.
But on that note, that's it.
And I'll be happy to
take any Q&A. Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, if you have any
questions, could you use--
are there microphones around?
Oh, yeah could you use
a microphone, please?
Yeah, question?
Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a hibernate dialect
for Cloud Spanner already?
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Is
there a what dialect?
AUDIENCE: A hibernate, for Java.
You're a Java developer.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: We usually use--
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
Oh, I'm sorry.
No, I don't believe so.
Next question.
Right here.
AUDIENCE: I have a
few simple questions.
First is, does the Spanner
do backups or something,
like this?
I didn't saw this.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
It's something
that the Spanner team
is working on right now.
It is not something that
exists in the product today.
AUDIENCE: OK.
The second question,
you said that Spanner
don't need downtime.
So how do Spanner make
[? re-indexing ?] call
of a [INAUDIBLE]?
When there are a lot
of updates on our DMS,
so you have to re-index
the index because it's
too large to data it has.
Does Spanner need to re-index,
or it run automatically?
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: No, I'm not
sure I got your whole question.
But we don't do
automatic indexes.
You can create
indexes on tables.
AUDIENCE: No, I'm asking--
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Work.
I'm asking when-- so another--
another way.
Does the Spanner do [? vacuum ?]
out of the [INAUDIBLE]
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Oh,
auto [? vacuum. ?] OK, like--
like garbage collection, and
cleaning up rows and stuff
like that?
Yes, yes it does.
AUDIENCE: Also if indexes are
[? run out, ?] or do you know?
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
I believe so,
but I'm not 100%
sure on that one.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
Any other questions?
Yep, right there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
[INAUDIBLE]
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: I'm sorry.
Is that working?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, is this better?
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Yeah,
really close to the mic,
please.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Is Google planning on open
sourcing this technology?
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: I'm sorry.
What?
AUDIENCE: Open sourcing
the Spanner technology?
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
Open sourcing Spanner
as a technology, I don't
believe that is part of the plan
right now.
Yeah, I don't think so.
AUDIENCE: So that means no
on-premise [INAUDIBLE] ever.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
Well, I mean,
we do have a lot of white
papers that describe
how Spanner actually works.
So it's theoretically possible.
And, in fact, actually, I
can't remember the name,
somebody has actually
created an open source-- hm?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
Cockroach, thank
you, yes, is an open source
version of Spanner that's
based off the Spanner paper.
But that was not released by us.
Any other questions?
One more here?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for the
presentation, very interesting.
The question is about, so
this is globally scalable,
but, at the same time,
transactional database, right?
How do you with the looks of the
tables, or records, et cetera?
And does it affect the
user's experience globally?
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: We don't
[? lock ?] tables or rows.
You can go into more detail
in the paper, which will
explain it better than I can.
But loosely speaking, it is
based off of time stamps.
So we're pretty-- we have an
extensive time stamp system.
It's mostly based on
satellites and atomic clocks
in the data centers.
So we have as precise
as we possibly can
with an acknowledged
amount of drift time stamps
for every single transaction.
And they are
reconciled by a master.
In a regional setup, there
is somebody who is in charge,
and we elect leaders on a
relatively regular basis that
is in charge of deciding
what came before
and what came after.
And so we have ordered
transactions that way.
And so you expand that
to a global setup,
and it functions the
same sort of way.
But it's mostly
based off of that.
But you can get a lot
more and probably better
detail from the white papers.
In fact, actually, as part
of the documentation website,
there are links to
all the white papers
that have to do with Spanner.
So the original
Spanner paper that
came out about 10
years ago, they
did an update one this year.
And there was one that
was written by Eric Brewer
to specifically discuss
how Spanner handles the cap
theorem, which actually goes
into a lot of what you just
discussed about how to reconcile
which transaction wins when
they come in.
And a lot of it has to do with
having really good time stamps,
but then also acknowledging
that nothing's perfect.
AUDIENCE: OK, one
small question.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So, it is only
Cloud solution, yeah?
We cannot use it as on-premises.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Unless
you want to use Cockroach, no.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
Any other questions?
Cool.
Cocktail hour.
Thank you very much, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]